ん
はいてられてる
予算コツは入選句です
今日の商品はこちらですマニュアル
すっ
今回こちらのそうゲオで買ってきました
値段の方は弱75万です
クロトはこんな感じになってます
エンブルがこんな感じになってます
湖で好きで夏らしいですね人はこんな感じになってます
うずら式で水リッジはこんな感じになってます
夏らしくでみずみずしいですね
さっそく1つ食べてみようと思います
さっそく開封していきたいとおもいます
入ってるはい今1センチほど上げてみました
いい音しましたねいい音しますねそれではさっそくハリアーに乗ってみようと思います
愚弟時期はこんな感じになってます
にゃんでどうなってがありますです
すごいなんか乗りやすいですね夏はしっかり食べるらしいですね
えっ
今乗ってみました
内部はとても静かですね
こちら側ハンドルですアントラーこんな感じになってます
こちらなぁ
前カレバーですね
こんな感じなカーンん
ここを水見るしてで珍しいですね夏らしいらしいです
そこであのサクシードレートをつけてみたいと思います
はい今つけてみました風という音がとても夏らしくて湖
これで早速運転してみたいと思いますもうすげー
ユーゼックステーションカラーうわぁ凄いですね
すぐ夏らしくてみずみず year is c 弾みだしね本当に
それでは皆さんさいならー
お詫び
つーわけで先輩でした
ux かありがとうございました